hey guys it's max we just got in
samsung's brand new galaxy buds pro and
today we're gonna check these out
and compare them to the galaxy buds plus
and the galaxy buds live to see which
one
you should spend your hard earned money
on believe it or not
the new galaxy buds pro actually have
the worst battery life it says 5 to 18
hours over here
whereas the buds live if you're not
using a bixby function at six hours with
active noise cancellation and the oldest
ones are actually the best with 11 hours
just with the buds themselves now that's
just the earbuds themselves
if we factor in the extra battery that's
built into the cases
then the pros and the lives come out
ahead let's open these up
and look at that the case looks pretty
much identical to the galaxy buds live
case
but samsung is going with a matte look
just like on their new
s21 phones let's pop this open
oh wow that magnetic clasp that's nice
definitely a lot stronger
and they look really nice sitting there
inside the case let's check out the
strength of the magnets
all right so the beans fell out here's
our more traditional case
all right these are staying out they're
shaking a little bit but they didn't
fall but the magnets in here are
nice and strong it's very interesting
that i'm not saying a label
which bud goes into which side let's see
if it can close if you put it the wrong
way and if the galaxy buds live
it will not close yep same thing here
but it definitely is interesting that
they ended up switching that now
another thing that i have to mention is
that i actually like
the design of the galaxy buds plus case
it's a little bit more slender it is
longer it's slightly thinner
but i feel like it fits into your pocket
easier especially if you want to put it
into a jean pocket if you have a wallet
in there as well
compared to this new square design as
far as prices
there is a big difference now when these
came out
the bus plus were 150 the buzz life
stepped it up to 170
and the pro are now 200 dollars but of
course there are some great sales going
on
so you can get these two for much
cheaper we're going to go ahead and
leave some links down in the video
description
where you guys can get the best prices
as far as the design of these buds you
guys could tell that there's a big
difference the galaxy buds live really
stand out they look like
little beans and they are not an in-ear
design
they just sit right in your ear canal
and they are
very comfortable i can wear these for
about twice as long as the original
galaxy buds plus let's go ahead and put
these on and
i've had a lot of experience with these
before so they feel pretty good like
standard in-ear
earbuds and what's very interesting is
look at the difference
in the opening here and then we also
have an
oval shape instead of a circular shape
and this whole
ear the silicon tip here it is much
thicker and has a lot more cushion
compared to this one which is super thin
and as soon as i press down i feel the
stem
whereas here i don't so let's put these
in
of course i will be doing a long-term
review and i'll be talking about
comfort and how long you can wear these
without my ears getting tired
but wow they are definitely more
comfortable just for my first
impressions
i don't feel the stem anywhere near as
much
as with the galaxy butts plus now the
galaxy bud pro earbud
does look larger and a lot more
substantial they actually filled in the
area where these wing tips
were and then on the bottom you also see
it's a little bit
of like a bulb here so they're
definitely making the most use of that
space that is available but it's
interesting that the pros don't stick
out any more
than the pluses and the lives are
actually the most
flush and as far as weight these
actually weigh the same even though the
pros are
larger and now let's go ahead and pair
these before we start testing out the
sound quality
active noise cancellation and
microphones and unfortunately
the galaxy buds wearable app for ios has
not been updated
yet and i cannot pair these earbuds
to my phone using that app i mean i can
still go into my bluetooth settings
and then they should show up here bam
they are connected and they do show up
as galaxy buds pro
but unfortunately i'm not going to be
able to customize any of the settings i
do have an android phone for that
which we'll take a look at in just a bit
but let's take a listen to how they
sound
default i'm going to start out with the
galaxy buds plus and then we'll listen
to the pro see if there's any difference
and then do the lives we're going to
start out with this classic song we'll
have a couple other genres
let's go ahead and hit play
[Music]
sounds good
[Music]
good seal here nice vocals i mean these
sound good i love how the galaxy buds
flush out
good base there these have dual drivers
and the new galaxy buds pro also have
dual drivers so you have a separate
tweeter
and a woofer for the base let's see if
we have any difference and once again
these are using the stock
settings i have not changed anything i
did put in the larger ear tips to make
sure i have a good fit
the highs are more crisp i think the
speakers are the same in here the
drivers maybe it's just the tuning
the base sounds pretty much the same
[Music]
the highs definitely stand out more
they're a little bit sharper which does
sound good
and now for the galaxy buds live
let's pop these in very easy to slip
these in and they don't go out
at all wow
these get loud definitely louder than
other ones
[Music]
i gotta say
these might sound better the bass
nice and rich
[Music]
the vocals still sound good alright
let's go ahead and pause that
in this song which is an edm song lots
of bass
lots of vocals the vocals and how high
and how crisp the highs are
it's right between the galaxy buds plus
and pro at least out of the box of
course you can tune these
sound the vocals sound great these get
louder and the bass sounds
really rich as well in this song i have
to give it to the lives
closely followed by the pros and in
third place the pluses but it's still
fairly close all right let's go ahead
and switch to our second song
and for the next one we have this kind
of a jazzy
classical mix it's called classic
and i'm gonna listen to all three and
then i'll give you guys my thoughts
[Music]
so i have to say wow
the earbuds that i probably would
recommend to the least amount of people
are the only ones that i
didn't want to stop listening to of
course you can't eq all three of these
but out of the box the bass not only
is it a little bit more present it's
richer and it's
deeper sounding with these both the
galaxy buds plus
and the pros the bass sounds pretty much
identical
the difference here is the highs are
much more crisp on
the pros and in fact in this song with
the hi-hats a little bit too crisp from
my liking
lives though these are the only ones
that gave me that kind of a sound stage
feel where the sound just isn't in my
ear
ear canals but there it's kind of wider
and you have this nice transition in the
part of the song
where you have to sweep and it sounds
much closer to my airpods max which is
what i want to be listening to
with this song now we're going to push
these to the limits listening to a rock
track and the galaxy buzz lives are the
only ones that don't have dual drivers
compared to these two
so they should have an advantage but
let's take a listen
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right guys so i was not expecting
that we have the galaxy buds live that
don't have
dual drivers that samsung is advertising
and they definitely
sound better i mean this is the toughest
test the galaxy
buds plus they're not cutting it it's so
thin especially with rock music the
highs aren't crisp enough
the mids are really lacking the pluses
and i think it might just be tuning
they sound better the high stained out
the vocals stand up better it's not all
muddy together
and they're a little bit louder as well
which is interesting but then you throw
in the galaxy buzz live
that rich bass the high still sound good
and what
really stands out is the mids you
actually get a nice
kick there in the mids i don't know it
just sounds great it's definitely
a step above the other two which i was
not expecting
and now let's go ahead and compare the
noise cancellation
the galaxy buds plus have passive
cancellation because they do seal
in whereas the other two have active so
in this room we have a loud vent
up there and we have the furnace
constantly running which is annoying but
let's take a listen
okay i can hear it but i would say
probably about eighty percent of it is
blocked
out and pretty much all the high
frequencies are blocked out
actually let's let's try the galaxy buds
live first
this time go and switch and i hear
almost as much as i would without them
because they don't seal into your ear
all right and now let's turn it on all
the low noise is gone completely
but i still hear some of the high
frequency sounds now
whoa okay that kicked it right away and
actually that was just
the off mode i thought the active noise
cancellation was running but no it's not
and it's blocking out i would say more
than the pluses
with off probably because the ear tips
seal better and they're better designed
now let's go ahead and activate our
active noise cancellation
i still hear it i don't think this is as
good as the airpod pros but if you guys
want to see a comparison to those make
sure you guys
hit that subscribe button below because
i will be doing a comparison
i would probably have to say cut out
about 90 percent of that vet sound but i
could still hear it
um angelica go ahead and say something
one two one two
i still hear you pretty well let me go
to the off position
all right talk now one two one two no
you sound the same to be completely
honest i was expecting
more from the active noise cancellation
um so let's go ahead and do something
else i have a video of people talking
here i'm gonna play this
so of course low frequencies it works
not as great how does it work with this
kind of sound
my goodness there's almost no difference
so i gotta say that's a bit
disappointing and i've used a lot of
great active noise cancellation
headphones but let's go and give the
lives
a try
the lives make there's no difference
with that sound
with the kind of crowded people talking
sound there's no difference here
which i would expect but there's also no
difference or
very little difference on the pros so
that is very very interesting to me
of course i am going to be doing a lot
more testing in different environments
and i will get back to you guys in the
full review
but so far i'm not that impressed
like i was expecting to be now all three
of these earbuds do have an
ambient mode i'm going to start with the
galaxy above this plus and we'll
compare that that sounds weird and still
quiet let's go to medium
we'll keep the mic clear okay now i'm on
high and i gotta say this sounds
terrible and extremely artificial and
the worst i've said i've heard
in about six months but i have been
testing very good headphones
let me hit play on the sound here that
is really
really weird all right not good at all
let's go ahead and step
up to the galaxy buds live all right
these actually don't have
the ambient mode they just have an
option here in the labs to relieve
pressure with ambient sound and that is
kind of like an ambient mode but it just
adds a little bit of feedback in there
so let's talk i sound fairly normal
and then let me hit this here i hear
that
basically ignore a little bit of the
hyzer cut down and let's enable this
okay and that seems to just bring back a
little bit more of those highs
i can hear great as long as music's not
playing all right
and for the pros i'm talking the highs
are really cut down let's go to ambient
sound
wow that is a good improvement over the
galaxy buds plus and i'm set to medium
volume let's kick it up a notch here
let's go to extra height whoa okay that
sounds horrible
high sounds not bad fairly natural
medium is the most natural i guess but
it's not as loud
and i have to say that is a massive
improvement i wonder if that's just
because the microphones have been
improved the galaxy buds pro
do have one extra feature that is pretty
cool and this is something i wish the
airpod pros had
and that's the ability to detect your
voice when you're talking
and then automatically go into that
ambient mode
and then it'll go back if it doesn't
detect your voice within 10 seconds so
let's go ahead and hit start here
and now i'm talking let's see how long
alright basic yeah maybe about two
seconds or so
and it goes into that ambient sound mode
that actually works really well
you don't have to uh go and switch modes
by yourself if you just have active
noise cancellation enabled you start
talking and it switches
that is an awesome feature and now let's
go ahead and test out and compare
the microphone quality and you guys take
a listen you let me know which one
sounds best to you this is the
microphone quality of the galaxy buds
plus
and this is the microphone quality of
the galaxy buds
live and this is the microphone quality
of the new
galaxy buds pro and now let's get to the
verdict
which one of these buds should you buy
before i give you guys my final opinion
i do have to mention that the galaxy
buds pro
do have some additional features that we
haven't covered
there is a 360 degree reality kind of
sound which i haven't tested because i
don't have a samsung phone right now i'm
letting a friend borrow my note 20. you
also have the auto
voice detect which works great you have
that ambient mode that
actually sounds good and is usable i'm
using it right now i would not be able
to do this
with the pluses and the galaxy buds pro
actually have ipx7 water resistance or
waterproofing that means that you can
actually fully submerge these
up to one meter in depth for 30 minutes
and they should be fine so do these
upgrades make the galaxy buds pro
worth spending almost twice as much
as the galaxy buds plus if you guys are
using those links in the video
description
or should you maybe go for the galaxy
buds
live now to be completely honest this
decision is much harder than i expected
i expected the pros to sound great
i expected the active noise cancellation
to smoke the galaxy buds
live but it really doesn't i didn't
expect the galaxy buds
live to sound the best either if you
aren't spoiled by high-end sound quality
you just have
cheap earbuds that you've been using um
i probably would just
save the money and go with the galaxy
bud supply now if you're somebody that
wants the best
sound and you don't care about sound
leakage and about having active noise
cancellation with the high frequencies
the galaxy buds live are on sale now at
a great price and they sound fantastic
they're very comfortable
and they just do a really good job as
long as you don't need the active noise
cancellation many of you guys even those
you guys that use android can
go for airpod pros and these are on sale
right now basically the same price as
these
so i'm going to do another video
comparing these head to head against
each other and make sure you guys have
those notifications enabled
click that circle above to subscribe and
check out one of the other great videos
right over there
this has been max and i'll catch you in
the next one